there's Facebook Twitter Pinterest
Google+ and Instagram just to name a few
the tangled web of social networks
leaves small business owners like
flourish Appel ski scratching their
heads social media is the new word of
mouth this is how people are talking
about so I am embarrassed to say I i
haven't believed in it flores business
manufactures and sells high-end wigs the
cost anywhere from two to ten thousand
dollars every wig comes with Flora's
personal touch and privacy it's not an
item that you walk by and say I'm gonna
go buy me a wig and this is a very
different kind of customer a shop owner
relationship because this is very
personal this is a very personal thing
to buy it's a marriage today though
she's not giving a customer a makeover
she's getting one from social media
expert Gary Vaynerchuk if you're not on
Facebook and Twitter in 2012/13 you're
basically not a relevant business in our
society 53% of small businesses use
social media that's up from 44% last
year but Vaynerchuk says few use it
effectively everybody thinks about
social media as promotions as email as
talking Twitter more than Facebook or
anywhere else is about listening less
pushing the PR that you've gotten or
that you've opened a store and more
searching on Twitter to jump into the
conversations Facebook is different if
you were to jump into some of these
conversation on Facebook they'd be upset
Facebook's much more private it's your
profile but you've had a hundred two
people like this page they want to
receive information the goal to get
people online to spread Flores message
but to find those people she needs to
look beyond Facebook and Twitter if you
are lucky enough to be in the women demo
and really try to story tell to women
Pinterest is becoming almost a must and
then if you're looking for the hipster
younger crowd that's when you get into
tumblr by you taking pictures of
Instagram and taking those pictures and
putting it out people will see it 15 20
30 people at I'm not in one lump sum but
they'll share it and that's one platform
I think Instagram is a must for you as
well
it may take some time to master the
social media web but flora has mastered
one crucial step posting here her first
Instagram picture Christine Romans CNN
New York